hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about bloating indigestion
constipation and acid reflux if you have
one or more of these this video is for
you now I just want to make it really
really simple because what's being
taught out there is completely the
opposite of what you need to know to
correct these symptoms now there is only
really kind of four things you need to
know okay got the stomach liver
gallbladder pancreas okay so the
stomach's right here gallbladders here
gallbladder and pancreas okay so the
stomach breaks down food the purpose of
the stomach is to break down mainly
proteins and absorb minerals okay
calcium iron potassium those are the two
big functions not to mention kill off
microbes and bacteria and things like
that so it needs to be very very very
very very very acid okay between one and
three if you know about pH that's like
that's like really really low okay now
if that pH is not acid enough you will
not be able to have that acid trigger
the liver to release the gallbladder
fluid which is bile so let me explain
what bile is bile is a fluid to help you
break down fats and it actually extracts
fat soluble vitamins it helps you absorb
fatty acids healthy fats which basically
make up all yourselves so this is a very
very important organ so we have the bile
it's made by the liver but it's stored
by the gallbladder okay if you don't
have a gallbladder well then you have a
tube but you still have bile that comes
out and you're usually going to be
deficient so a lot of times if the
stomach is not strong enough you won't
release the bile so now you have a bile
deficiency then you're going to get
bloating so we have a primary stomach
problem secondary gallbladder problem
okay one of the main symptoms for
gallbladder is Burke being belching and
right shoulder pain and then we get the
pancreas the pancreas does a lot of
stuff but the main thing it does with
rejection is it makes most of the
enzymes in the body and
enzymes breakdown food different like
carp you have enzymes for carbohydrates
starches proteins fats okay so these
little guys work together they break
down the food and and then they end up
in the small intestine where microbes go
in there and break down even more okay
so really if this stomach is not acidic
enough you can't release the bile and
you can't release the pancreas as well
as and so you get the situation when you
get undigested food okay that rots and
it sits right here and not to mention
all the other issues with you know pain
stomach pain bloating constipation and
then if this pH isn't strong enough this
valve right here won't close and they
call that GERD okay they call the acid
reflux because the acid is going to come
up here so acid reflux is really is a
situation we have not enough acid okay
so what do people take antacids oh my
gosh what a mistake because now not only
did you not fix anything you made it
worse okay so let me show you what I do
now I usually do a combination I
probably use these two remedies right
here and I'll explain them in a bit
probably 99% together I use them
together because I'll tell you why a lot
of the symptoms from the stomach could
mimic the symptoms from the pancreas
that can mimic the symptoms from the
gallbladder so a lot of times they can
cross over and it's hard to know what is
causing what so the first thing I do is
I really acidify the stomach and I use
something called a concentrated
acidifier called apple cider vinegar
plus which has a lot of apple cider
vinegar in a concentrated powder pill
with betaine hydrochloride which is an
acidifier so you take like two or three
with the meal right before you eat and
that starts acidify the stomach okay
that corrects the stomach and that alone
will really help the bile to be released
and the pancreas to be released so this
is a very powerful common commonly used
product that I use in a lot of people
because so many people have a problem
with this especially as they age they
lose the stomach acid and the list goes
on and on and on of all the reasons why
they lost
mechanics now this other thing I use
which is called a formula has some
actual purified bile salts in it which
will helps it helps give what your body
is missing a lot of times if you don't
have enough bile this gives you what
you're missing and it really helps you
fortify the liver and the gallbladder to
digest in for bloating but if the
stomach is not acid sometimes on a rare
case you take gallbladder and you might
alkalis because because the gallbladder
is alkaline alkalis this problem and
make you a little bit worse but that's
rare but it can happen
so if someone takes the gallbladder
without the certifiers sometimes they'll
feel more bloating so I just add the
acidifier boom everything works out nice
okay so with that bile in there now you
can lubricate the whole colon that's
what helps the constant patient okay
also helps absorption of vitamin A for
the eyes the skin the sinuses that's
vitamin A deficiency
okay also the in the gall bladder
formula I actually have pancreatic
enzymes so now a gallbladder actually
helps both of these areas at the same
time so it actually gets the pancreas to
work better and it gets the gallbladder
work better and then we add the
acidifier to really make it work better
so this will handle a lot of problems a
combination of these two right here so
you would take the gallbladder stuff
after you eat take one that's all you
need after we and take the acidifier the
upside of vinegar plus right before you
eat I usually like to take a little bit
like two or three of the episode of
vinegar tablets and then I like to take
one gallbladder after I eat to get a
full digestion you'll find they would be
very very satisfied because you start
pulling in more fats into the cell so
when you actually get complete digestion
the food can no longer sit right here
anymore so you don't have that food
that's like in de Geste it's kind of
undigested sitting right there you don't
get any more bloating you get a complete
digestion so you get C constipation is
incomplete digestion and it's usually
stuck right here and so the food can
actually go through effectively and you
get more energy you feel better so these
are the two that I use for bloating
indigestion constipation
acid reflux and they work really
powerfully together so give it a shot
and write your comments below